Welcome to a beta retro Why don't we have some new friends
here?
Why don't we have some new friends here?
Why don't you guys introduce yourselves?
Okay, not me.
I'll go first.
Fuck you.
Pushes everybody out of the way.
I have a...
I said Coda from Idol, Gen 2.
I'm a dragon.
It's pretty cool.
Cool.
That's it.
That's all I got.
I take it.
Thank you, Blushes.
Ah, hello.
My name is Bree.
I'm not from Idol.
I'm just me.
I'm a buddy.
I like Elden Ring.
I play a lot of that game.
That's it.
That's my entire personality.
Thank you for clarifying that you were not from Idol.
I was actually really confused.
I was like, I can't believe we're from my company.
Oh, my God.
That's crazy.
Well, okay.
In my defense, in my head, you were going to go, like, Yuna
was going to go after Kai, and then I was going to be like,
oh, my God, I'm not an idol.
And then you were like, go, bring go.
I'm like, my rehearsal in my head didn't make sense.
Keep your enemies on their toes.
I'm at next.
I'm at Buta.
Hello, I'm Buta Juna Unagi from Idol Ian's First Generation
Isakai.
I'm an EO bitch.
Yippee!
Damn, it's better than me!
And I'm Doki Bird.
I think that's a good enough intro, I think.
I am standing.
I'm short and thin enough.
It's great.
I'm like, I'm an indie.
You're also not an idol.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm not an idol.
Who would have thought?
But these guys, these guys, oh my gosh, these guys, they
came in here in this like an hour before this the stream
started i was so not used to it i was like looking at my
discord i was because we have a discord group for this
collab and they were like guys are you guys were you gonna
call now before the collab and i was like what so we can set
it up and everything and i was like whoa and then because
you got you got to come in early so you can set everything
by the way guys i showed up 10 minutes i showed up 10
minutes before the stream started all these girls were in
the call for an hour to 30 minutes and i was like all right
guys i'm gonna be here in like five to ten minutes guys yeah
no hi b and i were just like shitting our friends like oh my
god i can't believe dokey's fucking dead i actually called
it it's been 40 minutes we have 30 minutes it's okay i was
like i was like i wonder if she's sleeping i was yeah i was
like napping for like one or two hours and i woke up like 30
minutes before the stream started and i was like yay oh we
don't need an hour and you were actually like calculating it
and they were like no no because she put her waiting room
today like she's up right like she's not sleeping and i'm
like i don't know guys it could be it could be scheduled i
was so not used to this i was like you guys are freaking got
ready to get in an hour before i'm so used to people showing
up 10 minutes before the collab story.
I was like, I was your best, Kai and I were hanging out
before the call, so we were just, we just moved it over to
the place.
And I came in, I was like, did you guys do the tutorial?
And they're like, no.
And I was like, oh.
I was like, all right, so you guys, what were you guys
prepping?
Listen, we're prepared.
We're just prepping the vines.
Do you guys prepping?
I didn't do the, I have an excuse for not doing the tutorial
i showed up 10 minutes before the stream well well should we
get started and see how like shit our mics are in game oh
yeah by the way there's like um in-game mic uh so like my
audio guy you my audio guy was like everybody's balanced i
was like yeah for now but we're gonna be using in-game mic
later so you gotta figure that stuff out soon okay are you
guys ready yep i'm ready so For those who don't know what
this game is about, this is basically apparently for the
people who tested this game an hour early, they told me it
was like Dead by Daylight and Among Us mixed together.
So there's only one person who's the demon that's gonna kill
all of us.
And I was the one that suggested a game because I saw there
was a priest and that was the only character I wanted to
play.
So I was like, Kai was the priest when I got in the waiting
room.
I was like, get the fuck off the priest.
I'm only playing this game for the priest.
And get the fuck off.
I got the bullet.
I'm literally...
I literally I've been looking for Get off fucking priest You
were an invited Yes Yeah you're right I don't know why you
would leave the tech stuff to me It's okay I believe I don't
For the priest I looked at the controls because I was I was
nervous so I got I was I was sitting up at like three o
'clock in the afternoon.
I was so ready It's seven now.
Oh my god.
You guys are so I'm so prepared.
I've never done this before in my life I've never had it.
I have not had a collab starting time in a long ass time I
remember like when when it was like you know the the
designated time to start the stream They were like oh my god
guys it's time to start the stream.
I looked at the time was like 4 p.m.
I was like what 410 or 415 we're at the starting at four
exactly oh my god hey we're spoiling you no no no it's okay
i like i like the numbers not ready for this all right are
you guys are we all ready to go in yeah wait the host starts
it everyone wait how do we start it oh yeah oh go away i'm
gonna meet
All right, here we go.
Whoa.
Press... Hello?
I hear you.
Are we... Oh, my gosh.
You're the priest.
I'm the priest.
Okay, we got it.
We got to get... We have prep time.
We have the prep time.
It's like Batman.
We have prep time.
Okay, there's a shockwave.
Oh, my gosh.
Maybe we should have done the tutorial.
What are all of these?
Oh, my God.
I have stats.
Just my skills?
Oh, no.
Right click.
Oh, I want the dove.
I want the power of the dove.
I want the gun.
Why wouldn't I let me have the gun?
We don't have enough XP.
All right.
Oh, no.
What did I grab?
Orbs that spin around you and weaken the...
Okay, I got the orb.
I can only pick one.
Why do you have just these crew?
Well, you have a dove.
You have a gift.
I have the orb.
don't worry I have I have the orb Alright here we go Alright
it's time to It's time to kill Juna We never liked her in
the first place right
That's looking right I just met Okay that's not a lie I
didn't just meet her I met her at a convention but I mean
and greet but like but like I heard like I was her oh she
and I thought what this would be the perfect time to kill
her to say never meet your heroes never meet your heroes
she's gonna learn the hard way I have this we have oh shit I
not we have to do tasks okay find a crochet tool i need a
crochet unlock the armor door fight evil spirits whoa who
the fuck is she is that you juna who is she no i think it's
an npc there's npc yeah the guy can disguise as npcs and
then eat other npcs wait what the oh she doesn't she didn't
do the tutorial you were the only one that did the tutorial
so it's fine we have the only person that's wait hello hey
lady okay wait there's meds yeah yeah i got the bandage i
don't know how to use it but i got the bandages neither do i
oh i can lock the doors too but demon beam okay wait what's
this hide and beware to don't you don't see me guys guys
juna's right here oh my god she's so she's oh that's juna
that's her be gone oh you're stunning all of us oh did i
stun you i don't
okay okay all right we're fine yeah okay juna's got me okay
i know what she looks like now though oh wait i have this
you because i immediately forgot i found the crochet tool i
found it oh you got the crochet tool yeah we gotta unlock
the armor door with the pick tool who we who has the pick
tool oh oh wait is the crochet is the crochet tool the pick
tool oh maybe that is yeah
door guys i think guys i have a feeling that maybe we should
have done the tutorial
we'll be fine because i'm like i have so many like we're
being i have so many items but I try to figure out how to
pull up my...
Oh, I...
Oh, if you press tab, you can pull up your items.
Oh, yeah.
I healed myself.
I just got pills.
That's it.
I don't think Juna knows what she's doing.
Wait, let me bring up my game volume a little bit.
Ooh.
Okay, I brought up my game volume.
Okay, you know, I thought this would be a lot scarier, but
it's kind of not that bad.
It's not that bad.
I think it's also because we're grouped up together.
I don't know I saw I just got a tutorial on how to hide in a
closet.
So like we need a fun I think it's also easier right now
because we're together.
So we're not as scared I think Junet does not know where the
fuck we are.
I Think she's equally as lost.
No, it's this demon gets closer.
Wait, no, I think she might be nearby Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, I can't No, she's not Is she close to is she still
close by?
What the fuck what's that?
Is that June is that you?
Yes, the entire invisible potion.
She can't be invisible in here.
Oh, apparently she can be invisible.
Oh wait, there's a ladder here Whoa, I thought June just
like the biggest heart or something.
I got a ladder I don't know what to do with it.
I just got the ladder.
Oh, there's more bandages.
Wait.
Uh, Bree.
Whoa.
Oh, okay.
She inked.
I got scared.
Okay.
It's just some old woman.
Breathe.
Take the bandage.
Take the bandage and like here.
Press tab and then click on the click on your bandage.
All right.
More pills.
Oh my God.
Am I injured?
Yes, you are.
Look at your HP.
What do you mean?
Am I?
I injured?
I didn't know.
Bro, Judo's be so funny.
She looks good.
She is like so fucking confused.
I wonder if there's like...
Wait, wait, stand still.
I'm gonna use this gun on you.
Ow.
Oh, that's injured you.
What?
I'm...
Oh, yes.
What the fuck?
I thought it was heal.
I thought it was healing.
What the fuck?
Well, don't keep doing it.
Don't keep, I'm fucking healing myself right now.
There you go, there you go.
Well, you had a little bit left, so I was like, oh my god,
I'm gonna help you.
Don't make me use this.
Wait, what?
Wait, wait, wait, she was next to us!
She was next to us!
Yeah!
Yeah, we fought!
Oh my god!
Bro!
I can't believe it.
I wanted to hurt you guys, put it in a three minute task
failed successfully it would have been great oh my god we
would go downstairs for you we find some armored door shit
my gamer senses was tingling oh don't worry watch this demon
is getting closer we're okay we're okay she's not close
enough whoa this is spooky
Wow!
What the fuck?
I'm sorry.
No, that was- Did you ink again?
Okay, okay.
I was gonna say, did you ink again?
I'm sorry.
You can't just keep throwing those at everyone.
Okay.
I can't.
There has- Wait, you have unlimited?
Actual menace.
You have unlimited- There's like a regen.
Oh, oh yeah, me too.
I do too.
Convincibility, I see.
What?
That has to be an NPC, right?
Yeah, why is that what he's flashing?
Yeah, because I hit him with my anti-demonic beam.
Yeah, I don't think that's an NPC.
Yeah, that's not.
That's an NPC right here.
Oh, my God.
Where the fuck?
This is...
Stop shooting me with the surprise!
The guy!
Oh, that's him.
That's him.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I...
Oh, I can't see.
Oh, FF, press F.
I have a Okay Here we go.
I'm doing it.
I did it.
She did it.
All right.
It's okay.
I said be gone and she disappeared.
Oh my god.
Guys, one of you guys must have played this game in my chat.
Where's the however?
We must have one person that played.
this game I'm so lost you have exercised a demon I'm so lost
I should not be needing anybody in this game I don't know
where anything is oh my god wait what's this oh this thing
they heal at this thing oh the thing that when we heal them
she has to go back here tutorial I think that just leads out
Someone said I just realized I have a syringe and I have a
syringe gun and I was using the syringe Oh my god, please.
You're not healing No, you're not.
What are you doing?
Just poke.
All right, let's make sure that no one's near us why you do
that Okay, here I did say she was getting closer
Nothing.
Oh, okay.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Oh, hey, I think she's close by.
Yeah, I can't hear.
I see like, be gone.
Oh my god, I can't fucking see now.
I know.
It's the anti-invisibility, but also with the anti-sight.
Well, that is her!
What the fuck?
Be gone!
Wait, no, that's not her.
That's an NPC.
This NPC was like, help.
This group of girls are gay and beating me up.
We fucking beat up an old man.
Oh, no.
Wait.
We beat up some...
She took damage.
What the fuck?
That was her.
Wait, are you okay?
Oh, she's not okay.
Get up.
I know.
You can get up.
Don't be a little bitch
What are you doing?
Be gone We can't be gone.
Oh shit, bro.
She's beating us up I think because she's she's like they
possessed him I think it's cuz like I think it's cuz I mean
she's She's taking damage.
You can see on her HP that she's taking damage.
Don't worry.
I'm getting coming over.
You can't hide from us Drew that we're gonna kill you Get
over her.
I have more spells Get over Look at her right She's right
here in front of me Be gone Get out of here Oh
She disappeared.
She went invisible.
She went out.
Wait, I have a thing for this.
God, she's gone.
What a little bitch.
What a little.
Okay, I'll save her.
Don't worry.
God is in you.
I saved her.
Yay.
Don't worry.
Not believe in God.
I'm a fucking loser.
God is real.
Wait, I see her.
She's like right here.
June I see you yes where did she go I saw her fucking there
I don't know I like how we gave up on the armored door wait
can I wait God you're healed that would be yeah please
actually use your syringe don't stab me to death please use
your syringe Ow!
What are you doing?
She's losing HP!
I think I'd rather have Drew to kill me at this point.
Oh, I see her.
I see her.
She's right here outside this door.
She's right here.
Oh, there she's coming!
She's coming!
Oh, no!
Bro, are you a medic?
Where did you get your fucking degree?
You can't...
You literally...
You literally have blood!
Your one job!
Your one job is to heal us!
But I can't chunk some of her!
What the fuck?
She's not vegan!
She lost half of HP because you shot her!
Oh my god, okay, look, as someone that's not a priest,
here's to take these pills and heal yourself.
Oh yeah, I wasted all my pills on myself as well.
Like that wait, I have three how do I yeah, you just left
click it.
What are you doing?
These pills are for you to no You're the one that needs HP.
I can take some too.
Look I'm better now Please what are you doing?
What the fuck are you doing?
I'm trying to figure out.
Take the HP Breathe breathe I for the healing free for the
life love of god to ask your chat how to play your character
for the love of god
can you hold hold let's just hold the deal oh my god have
you not been holding Oh my
How is Juna taking damage none of us are doing anything and
she lost half she lost what
Okay What do you mean You haven't done anything!
You haven't done anything!
Anyway, guys, how's the sound volume so far?
How's the game volume so far guys?
Where's the armory door?
Yeah, no, I'm trying to find it too, but I don't see
anything.
Like, I just don't know why.
Oh, wait, well, in the basement, maybe.
Do you think it's in the basement?
Oh, yeah, it could be.
Oh, come on.
That's always in the basement.
Oh my god.
Do you think oh it's here?
Where's it?
Oh dude.
Holy shit.
You're so smart.
Oh my god.
Oh my god Wait, here.
I found it.
I found it
Wait, I think so I'm right here follow my boys Dude guys.
I don't think Judah knows there's a basement or guys I don't
think Judah knows there's a basement.
We're so we're so okay
There's hope there's no way she knows there's a basement
Wait, wait, wait, what to go back down?
That's the outside Wait, I don't I don't think we're back.
I think we found a different area.
No, no, there has to be an armor door Wait, what's this?
I found it how to oh, I found it guys guys.
I'm a priest I don't know how to do lock picking How the
fuck?
How the what oh I did it?
What?
I did it!
Oh, you did it!
I don't know what I did!
I think she...
Oh my god, there's...
Oh my god, there's evil...
Oh my god, turn around!
There's a thing here!
Oh my god!
Ow, I'm taking damage!
How do I...
Begun!
Oh my god, I took so much damage.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Go in!
I believe you!
Begun!
Guys, I'm not doing anything.
Guys, I'm not doing anything in this room.
I...
Oh, I'm doing it!
No, they're doing damage.
They're taking damage.
I'm doing it.
I'm saying stuff in my book.
I stopped saying things in my book, guys.
Oh, wait.
Are you?
Sorry, that was me.
Oh, okay.
Wait, one of them is gone.
Wait, I think you were doing...
I think it was your job.
Is it?
Yeah, you fucking stopped.
You, like, Ghostbusters that shit.
Not doing anything guys.
I mean you did damage with the book.
Yeah.
Yeah, you were ghost bustering Yeah, it was you that was
your job.
Okay, okay Okay, okay as I have bandages Okay, the princess
bandages try get over here.
What the fuck?
What are you doing here Juna leave Juna?
We're doing our thing.
There's I'm sure Kai!
Kai, Kai, come over here.
I have bandages.
Kai!
Kai, get over here.
I have bandages!
I have bandages right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, let me push up the game then.
I have...
Here.
That's a better faith than this.
All right, let me...
This heal.
All right, heal so you can get rid of the last guy.
We need you to get rid of the last ghost.
Literally, that's all we have to do.
That's okay.
I'll zap them.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
We shall- You're good!
Yeah, I'll just exist here.
I'll just- I'll just get rid of Juna for you.
Get away from us, Juna!
Get away!
Go away!
We're down!
We're doing our job!
What are you doing, Juna?
What the fuck is she is?
Yeah!
Demonic altar has been destroyed!
We did it!
Yeah!
We have more?
You know, I'm just like- Oh my god.
Oh wait, wait, I have matches, I have matches.
We can- I can- we just need to find the altar.
Yeah!
Wait, we too!
Yeah, we just gotta go find the altar.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, find the altars.
I feel like we saw the altars on the second floor.
I'm shielding you.
Okay.
I feel like having you medic is like, useless.
Oh,
my medic doesn't shoot us.
I'm doing something.
What the fuck?
No, you're not!
You are not doing anything!
What the fuck?
Be gone!
Oh, no.
Oh my god.
You are definitely not doing anything.
anything
oh my god let me save this believe in god I don't know I
feel like is it even worth it I feel like they give us I
don't know I need a benefit whoa oh he's just bro that's not
he's just a normal guy he's just a normal man what though
what what the fuck the demon took its final form for one
minute hi where's the closet oh no oh no oh no oh no guys
I think we'll be okay guys can you hear me there's no way
right
There's no way, right?
That they can hear me.
Right, guys?
We'll be okay.
Shh.
The team is no longer invincible.
We're okay.
Guys!
It's no longer invincible.
the ball guys guys wait i think kai's dead guys i think
kai's dead hello
oh you did your job you actually did your job i don't know
where you are but i can see kai is not
Oh Did you figure out how to be a medic now?
Did you finally figure it out?
Yeah, apparently I can only be a medic If you're dead.
I can't Now we know It's okay.
It's okay.
She's not invincible.
Oh Okay, okay, don't worry.
Oh, she is literally one HP.
You cannot shoot her anymore.
You actually She's literally one HP right now.
You cannot do that.
We gotta fire.
I feel like we've seen the altar before.
Okay, I'm gonna lock.
I'm gonna start locking doors.
I have the worst memory.
Holy fuck.
Wait, there's a meds.
There's meds.
Take the meds.
Wait, I think I remember there being like a, it was like a
room.
It was like downstairs and it was like a table in the middle
of the floor and that was it.
That yeah, yeah, that has to be why would there be a table
in the middle of the floor that has to be yeah, I don't know
All right, let's see Oh my god Just in case just gotta be I
gotta be sure No, are you sure?
Okay, you look I'm not feeling so confident.
She's like the our only lead right now.
So Yeah, oh my god.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay.
I think it's my job Okay, wait, whose job is this whose job
is this?
Is this my job?
how do i light it do we light the door i lock the door so
she can't get in i don't think how do we do this whose job
is this oh i don't know wait wait this is the ritual table
wait wait wait it's placed the parchment on the ritual oh
that's the ritual okay this is not a okay that's not the
okay that's not the okay we know where it is okay someone
marked okay remember this You gotta remember this.
You're literally our only hope.
You're our guy Awful with directions.
Okay, that's terrible because so am I.
Okay, so This is bad with this This was what we look like
this is what they look like.
Okay.
They're basically a table.
We know what they look like now There was like a flag on it.
Yeah.
We know what they look like now Oh the range was not far
enough.
Sorry I think Oh, there he is!
Oh my god Give me a sec, my cooldown I have a cooldown!
Oh, you're gonna protect Kai, okay Okay Okay Be gone!
Okay, he's not here, she's not here She's not here
Okay, she's not here Oh, she, oh, goodbye Kai I think I'm
the only one that can fight back I'm pretty sure I have a
few like buffing or like debuff I can slow her down and then
my my gunshot is apparently good against her I'm pretty sure
like the end slightly I'm pretty sure the engineer is like
the one that actually all the exorcism stuff and i'm just
here to fight the demon
we just need one more i can show it to her later she'll cry
we just need one more whoa what does that mean what what
does it sound what there's a sound i didn't hear anything I
think you're fucking paranoid right now.
We literally just need one more.
Where the fuck is the last altar?
It has to be on this floor.
I know God.
Be God!
Is she?
Are she gone now?
Oh, she's gone.
Guys, we're back here.
Okay, she is not a coward.
She was not a cat.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Watch this.
Come on.
That's fucking right.
What are you doing?
What the fuck are you doing?
Oh my god, get around!
Oh my god, what is she doing?
Bro, she gave you a freebie, bro.
Bro, that was like a fucking strip club right there.
We were, like, at a bachelor party, and we hired Judah to
have...
And we're like, hey, yeah.
Oh, she was like...
Literally, like, she's, like...
She was, like, straddling your waist.
Yeah.
And then...
And then I felt like we were at a bachelor party, and we're,
like, giving you a nice, like, birth...
One last day before you're hitched, bro.
You know what, honestly.
On my end, it literally just looks like she's beating the
shit out of me.
I'm trying so hard.
I'm trying so hard to heal you.
Oh my god.
Okay, we need one more.
There has to be the last fucking altar.
We probably like ran around it like a million times.
We probably have.
I found one of them.
Should we, I hate to say it.
Should we split up?
Okay, how about like since you're...
Okay.
No, no, no.
Bree should stick with Kai because Kai's the most fucked up
right now.
I'll just heal.
Okay, I don't have healers.
Okay, if I...
Okay.
I thought she was gonna say something.
Don't worry.
I'll split up with you guys and you two find the last altar.
All right, are you guys ready?
I'm the only one.
Okay, I'm going this way.
Yeah, don't worry.
Okay.
I'm believing you guys.
Come on.
I'm gonna see if there's an altar at the top floor.
All right, we'll go this way.
Yeah, you guys look at the bottom floor.
Just keep talking because I can still...
hear you guys on the second floor okay i can't hear them
anymore on the second floor i guess that was not true guys i
can't hear them anymore guys i sadly cannot hear them oh i
know what their hp is oh my god brie is almost can brie heal
herself We did it!
They did it!
Oh my god, it literally spawned next to me!
Guys!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna lock the door!
Guys!
Are you guys alive?
Guys?
Guys, guys, guys, I found the parchment!
Guys!
I don't know where it is.
Downstairs downstairs Downstairs oh I found the parchment I
found the parchment and literally spawned next to me when
you guys found the altar Oh, nice.
Okay, we gotta go.
Okay, we gotta go where is it?
Where's the thing?
We gotta go this way and then dining room table.
Okay, okay, okay I don't uh, you don't know where you're
going, do you?
No, I have confidence.
No, no, no, I always this way This way in the main lobby.
Oh my god, we're so good at this game.
There we go.
Dreda must have been so fucking confused.
Be gone, demon.
You have love for a demonic altar has been destroyed.
Wait, I can oh my god, I forgot.
I can heal us.
Do you guys know?
Your teammates two times faster during agony.
Observation.
What the fuck was recharge your observation yeah i'm gonna
be like wait we could have been like working on upgrading
ourselves oh no i maxed out on attack i'm gonna there's so
many okay defense i'm gonna put you like attack how do i
recharge your heal mana how do i heal
Where's my heal, mana?
If only there was something that could have told us what to
do.
I know.
I think she's outside.
Wait, hold on.
This is important.
I think she's outside.
What's the top button?
I think she is.
Wait, maybe if I like...
She can't be...
I swear to God, if I open it and it's her ugly ass face, I'm
going to lose my mind.
All right, here you go.
Let's see.
Oh, she left.
Okay, she left.
Okay, I swear to God she was out.
She can't be invisible in the east.
I'm helping you!
I feel like...
Oh my god.
I'm gonna put it on defense.
Fuck this.
Alright, we got fine.
Oh!
She's crawling the fuck!
Oh my god.
You must be like, why can't I kill them?
I was right Are you just hiding?
Oh, the breaker!
Eddie, do your job!
Right here, right here, right here, right here, right here,
I got it!
Oh my god, she shocked it at me!
God, she's fucking getting closer!
Get away!
Be gone!
Oh, okay, I think we got Brie Brie, we need you, Brie!
Get out of the fucking closet!
Oh, this is the fucking fighting for our lives, and she's
still...
Bree, I swear.
I'm not going after me because I'm just not a threat.
I'm just not helpful at all.
Oh, wait, wait.
She's almost dead.
Wait, I can kill her.
Oh, we got it.
We got it.
We can actually kill her.
Where is she?
Oh, hey, what's this?
Oh, that's one of the...
Wait for the wolves to enter the circle.
Wait, we have to like...
We have to find the meat.
Yeah, where the fuck is the freezer?
Okay.
It has to be up top, right?
I mean, I assume it's in the...
The kitchen, right?
Either in the basement or it's in the kitchen.
Yeah.
Did you just burn the...
Yeah, yeah, fuck that bird.
Fuck that.
What is that bird done for us?
I mean, the kitchen was up top.
Yeah, it was on the second floor, right?
Oh, it was here?
No.
Oh, no.
I don't know.
I feel like there has to be a kitchen on the second floor.
Yeah, I'm going to do the top.
Come on, guys.
It has to be on the second floor.
Oh,
don't worry.
Begun!
Okay.
All right.
I participated.
Come on.
It has to be.
Oh, someone said it's on the first floor.
Someone said it's on the...
Thank you.
I was right.
Thank you for that one guy that actually played this game.
the one person that played this game no not here no no how
many fucking laundry mats do they have oh right oh no i'm
lost oh how do i repair this breed breed breed why would
okay let's let's fucking do like house renovations too by
the way yeah yeah what do you guys oh wait but what if we
have to go through this later coming near again yeah well
well cares all right who's gonna win first i hope juna can
die like in this game
okay where the fuck is like are you sure okay maybe that guy
who said it's in the first floor lying to us because I swear
I swear to deceive her a liar where is the kitchen fucking
she's in here she's in here we need you Bri oh my god Bri
has to split up from all of us the most important person in
our team Bri oh I can save you I can save you oh okay okay I
saved him I saved her I saved her okay oh you found it
Birthday!
We got you a surprise!
Thank you!
Okay, it's this way!
It's this way!
I found it!
Holy shit!
All right.
It's here?
Where's the kitchen?
And then here.
Oh!
Oh, they turned off the power again!
Oh, I found...
Oh, hey!
I got all three!
Wait, what?
Oh!
What the fuck?
Don't worry.
Get the thing.
Be gone.
I got it.
Go get the electricity.
Huge, huge, huge.
All right.
We got it.
We now need to place the wood.
We got to go back.
We got to go outside.
I've zapped her a million times.
Yeah, but she's like what?
Oh, shit.
Guys, no.
Please.
God would not forsaken me.
Bro, I'm like hanging by the thread right now.
I'm hanging by the thread.
We got it.
I'm gonna grab the wood.
I've got wood.
It's fucking grim.
Guys, gang, we gotta get the wood.
We're carpenters now.
We gotta clean up.
We're like... It's okay.
I got three.
We need two more, guys.
We need two more.
Two more wood.
I was going to get hit by the bird.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Wait, we got it.
Place the wood around just you gotta get two more just get
in the car Just be like sorry.
This is just too much This is above our pay grade Like bro,
don't you enjoy your bachelor party bro?
Well, definitely never got to anything like this Bro, you
won't be able to do this anymore when you get your wife I
found another oh nice.
Okay, we gotta find another x Where's the other X?
Oh, another X.
Yeah.
Place the wood around the indicated.
There's like...
Yeah, but we already have enough, though.
Dude.
We already have enough.
We need...
Oh, whoa.
Oh, Brie did it.
Do you know where that...
Wait for wolves?
Where did she go?
Where the fuck did Brie go?
Brie, where are you, Brie?
Oh, there we are!
Oh, yeah!
There's some wolves!
Look!
There's the blobs!
Oh!
What help?
Oh, bitches!
Oh, she's gone.
She's gone.
We did it, guys.
We're like, what do you mean, help?
We're fine.
Yeah, I was just, I was kiting her.
I was kiting her around the post.
Like, what are you talking about?
We were maxed out stats.
We're maxed out.
Is that it?
Did we do it?
Did we win?
Yeah.
I guess we just kill her.
Demon's getting...
What?
Don't worry, I got you.
Oh my gosh.
I think we did it.
I think we're supposed to kill her now.
Finally not 1 HP.
Come on, Judah!
We're maxed out now!
Come over here and kill us!
Literally!
We did everything!
You won't!
Come on, Juna.
We're literally out in the open.
I shot her every time.
It's time.
Someone in my chat said that she can't heal anymore is what
we did.
So she's just like at that HP and she can't go higher.
Oh, that's right.
Juna, this is it.
1v3 us right now.
Oh, come on.
Get over here.
I would have like a Mexican stand on.
1v3, I'm like pushing hang by the thread right now.
I'm hanging by the thread 1v3 Tuna if anything just slap me
first Tuna just slap me first so I can get revived and have
back my HP That's fucking right be gone Shit okay she
slapped me guys guys she slapped me Okay guys thank God all
right we did it I'm okay I still don't know what the fucking
camera.
Oh, wait, there she is.
Wait, her footsteps.
Wait, where?
Wait, I can see, I can see her footsteps.
Yeah, but it disappeared.
Oh.
Juna, get down.
You know it's over, Juna.
Juna, it's over here.
Wait, what?
I lost her.
Wait, guys.
Wait, we split up.
That's not how we're supposed to do this.
Get back here!
Where is she?
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Guys, we got Chrissy!
Chrissy!
Yeah!
We did it!
Oh shit, wait, just fucking...
Hello?
Huge, hello!
It just kind of like how it just kicks us out of the game.
It really kicked you.
Wait, it kicked you out?
The kingdom.
I'm solid.
Oh my god.
It's the same lobby?
Yeah, same lobby.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
How was it, Juno, being the demon?
Yeah, what is it?
I was like, bro, like, how do I do the abilities?
And they're like, oh, you have to press like the, like F1,
F2.
And I was like, oh, but then I realized there was a fucking
scroll wheel, like at the end of the fucking game.
So the reason why I would just like stop and stand in front
of you guys.
And they're like, okay, I depressed F6 now.
Oh my god.
Bro, why do you you you guys want to die?
I was killing them.
I did my job.
You killed you.
And then you're still a killing.
What the fuck do you mean?
I can't believe you guys are inting in my race.
What is it?
What the fuck is it?
So it's being retro.
I can't fucking I can't believe this.
I can't believe you're inting in my high elo.
I don't know.
It just sounds like somebody who's just got skilled dived.
No!
But it was funny in the beginning.
B was like, oh, I read the instructions.
Like, she could kill NPCs, but she doesn't know if I was
standing in the same room as you guys.
I can hear you guys.
What is that?
You couldn't even hear us.
The visibility potion works.
I was saving it everywhere.
You know, because I was at the closet at some point.
have to be quiet what if she can hear me you're just like
i'm in the closet not the first time though and i was like
oh my god this i can't believe you can actually hear us dude
that just makes it so much who's gonna who's gonna be the
demon now all right not it not it we actually i'll do it
i'll do it all right okay let's swap roles he wants to be
the priest now i try to kill like i try to like hit the rest
of you guys but kai just kept like coming in front of me i
was like bitch
like oh my god you want me so bad like yeah you're like i'm
like i'm sick and tired of you i was like yeah uh-huh yeah
but why do you keep coming back to me okay i hope you
actually heal it says you have the ability to heal your
teammates quickly drop healing kits or spawn devices that
can increase the life of exorcists so yeah i'm a little
silly someone said that in my chat literally immediately as
the game ended they're like no no breathe the syringe
doesn't heal it's just melee damage like oh
my god wait don't you do you want priest or i'll be no no
i'll be the engineer okay okay now she now Now she's not
gonna go.
Whoa.
What can I do, actually?
Technology is your friend.
Install cameras, use various sensors, and weaken the demon
with advanced tool.
I don't even know if I can do that.
So it's such advanced tool.
Okay.
That's a lot of stuff that somebody not did.
Earn.
I don't think I've seen any of these things in that game we
play.
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, okay.
I'm meeting.
I started my bad.
Oh, yeah.
muting muting all right here we go oh my god look at all
these tools oh my god anti-demonic beam i'm gonna grab i
already have this spell there's an electric blower drive the
demon away i got a car what the fuck oh my god i need 200 xp
magnet detects useful when the demons become oh my god i can
grab so many items you can grab so many items guys just spam
grab them oh you just oh okay okay so you just grab all of
them yeah yeah you can grab multiple ones just spam clicking
okay i swear to god i swear to god
You have one job!
I nearly have seven items!
I didn't even read what they are!
I just kept grabbing!
Oh wait no, wait no, I have seven items too.
Yeah, I just kept grabbing.
Oh, so maybe you did- Gabers don't look up.
Okay.
Gabers don't look up.
Surveillance camera.
What the hell?
There you go.
Yeah, no, the monster had the, the monster had push to talk.
So I just like, unpushed to talk to myself.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, wait, really?
I'm gonna try and put...
Guys, do you think the demon's gonna go through this?
Guys, I don't...
I fucked it up.
Wait, the demon's already closed, though.
I don't want you telling me I'm ugly when you were looking
like you did before.
Oh, my gosh.
I couldn't find a fucking NPC and I had a bit of an ugly old
man.
Wait, I'm gonna be like, watch.
I gotta go to the spa.
You gotta get your nails.
I gotta, what?
What was that?
I heard a slam.
I got a car.
Look, look at this car.
Oh, that's so funny.
Guys, I like how nobody's protecting me while I'm in this
car.
I like, let me just be in this corner.
Nobody's in.
Oh, I just, wait, I think I got it.
Wait, is that a demon?
Demon?
Oh, he won!
That one!
She just won!
That's her, guys!
That's her!
I can't see anything!
Yeah!
That's her!
She's just looking at us!
Be gone!
Oh.
It's okay, guys.
I got us.
She's gone.
Whoa!
Oh, my bad.
My bad.
Okay, we did a bit of damage.
Like, I just stood there.
Oh, does that heal you guys?
She was just standing there.
She's like, I don't know what I'm doing.
Oh, that's a shield.
Okay, we got five.
Whoa!
Lights!
Where the lights are!
The circuit breakers.
Okay, okay.
Or the circuit breakers.
Don't worry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The priest is doing it.
The priest went to electrician school.
Before he became a priest, he went to trade school.
And then he found God.
He found God after.
Found God.
I have, like, cameras, but I don't think I'm going to use
the camera.
Don't worry.
I have no idea what the camera does.
I was trying.
I have no clue.
Don't worry.
I have movement, too.
I don't even think I picked up half of this stuff.
Oh, my God.
Demon gets closer.
Don't worry.
I have a metal detector.
Like, can I shoot the innocent people?
Oh, my God.
He's on me.
She's on me.
Oh, my God.
What the?
Please.
Oh, oh, this is the thing.
Oh my bad.
Oh my god, please.
Why is my priest not doing anything?
Why?
What the fuck?
Oh, there she is.
She's right there.
There she is.
Oh my god, get her out!
Get exorcist her out!
Get out!
Get that shit.
What the fuck she's doing?
guys we have to like you fucking think guys we have to
fucking yeah grab the electric i think rea actually knows
how to play this game that's crazy
wait is that you what is where you doing oh guys guys she
actually knows how to play the game guys
Where is the healer?
All I can fucking do is turn off the bombs.
Where are you not healing?
Please, I'm fucking...
I'm fucking...
Look at my HP!
I'm barely alive!
There she is again!
Look!
Maybe try stabbing her with the syringe.
Bro, I'm fucking free.
Like, free.
Just breathe the shit.
Ow!
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm dead.
Holy shit!
Oh, okay, here, here, here.
Okay, guys, let's just find the armored door.
The priest doesn't have any healing things, right?
No, it's only...
How do I...
I think you do, but you have to pick...
Find it.
Okay, we gotta like...
We gotta go to the basement.
Guys.
Come here.
Wait, are you actually healing?
No.
I don't know.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta...
Let's go.
We gotta find the basement.
I'm fucking...
I'm gonna heal myself.
I don't need you guys anymore.
You must have like we just gotta find the bandages.
We gotta like go to the basement.
I don't know.
What the fuck go away Stop touching What the fuck are you
doing to just touch that beside me?
We found the basement.
I found the basement The basement.
Oh Nice.
Oh, freeze stop
Please I can't see anything Holy shit.
Oh, there she is.
Oh, you're like dead.
Okay, hold on.
One second.
Don't worry.
I'm zapping.
I'm begun.
Oh my god, she fucking caught.
Oh, my.
Oh, shit.
Where's the light breaker?
Go away, breathe.
Go away.
I'm, where the fuck is the light?
I don't... I found it!
I found it!
Okay, here you go.
Oh my god.
I found it.
We gotta go downstairs.
I found the light breaker.
Where are you?
Let's go downstairs.
Okay, this has to be her.
That's her, by the way.
Hey, thanks, Bree.
Hey, Bree.
Thanks for taking us to the basement, Bree.
We really appreciate it.
See, she read the tutorial because she's gonna be- Oh my
god, she's got- No, you fucking killed it!
She was trying to take us to the- No what?
She was trying to take us to the- She was trying to take us
to the thing!
Oh, here it is.
I found it.
Yeah.
Oh.
Wait, we don't have the hooking tool.
Who has it?
Oh, shit.
It's your turn.
Go to it.
I don't even know what it looks like.
I- No, no, she has it.
She has to do- I don't know how I did it.
Just...
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
Use your cooldowns, priest.
What the fuck is this?
Make sure we don't get...
We don't get...
Are you okay?
What?
Okay, give me the hooking tool.
Give me the fucking hooking tool.
We can't protect you forever!
Oh, she did it.
She did it.
Oh, it's my turn.
My turn.
Watch.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
How did you do this?
I don't fucking know shit just blast them.
Okay, I'm gonna keep blasting This would work eventually,
right?
Oh, I did it.
I did it Don't worry.
I'll just just protect me.
I'll do my job.
Just protect me.
All right.
I'm literally one HP All right.
I don't have a lot of cooldowns
I don't get away.
We're doing our job, Brie Okay, I got here.
Let me just ceiling literally just all right just protect
me.
Yeah, just protect me while I do my actual job
Hey, yeah, give me a sec.
We have a lot of cooldowns here Be gone Oh my god, I can't
fucking Be gone Is it?
Is it stinky or sorry?
Ew.
Am I doing it?
How long?
How long did it take you?
No, no, no.
You're doing it.
How long did it take you?
Oh my god.
We gotta hide.
Fucker.
You fucker.
Oh.
There's no way she knows we're here, right?
There's no way.
Shut the fuck up, Kai.
Shut the fuck up.
She can't hear us.
Bro, she can't hear us.
Why are you fucking?
Why are you talking?
What is she talking for?
I mean, she knew I was in the fucking closet.
I'm like, girl, I'm not coming out.
Where is she?
Where are you?
Where did you die?
Dude, she literally died.
She died.
But where?
She was right in front of the closet.
Wait, she just died?
Oh shit.
I'm trying to exorcist this guy.
Oh no.
She's almost dead.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna- the- the- the spirits are almost dead.
It's almost dead.
I'm trying so hard.
I'm blowing him away.
There you go.
I did it.
Yeah, we did it.
Okay, this is a little awkward that...
Is she actually dead?
Dead for real?
Yes, yeah, yeah.
I think she's...
She died in front of me.
I saw her corpse.
You can die for real?
I thought it was just...
Yeah, I didn't know.
Yeah, I was waiting.
You can die for real?
I feel kind of bad, but like also...
know so she deserves it so like it's fine fine the key that
oh wait these are new quests yeah how do we get out of here
i don't know son oh i'm okay i'm not okay i'm not okay i'm
not okay oh my god you can do that this entire time yeah
yeah yeah yeah kai kai you have to pick me up kai kai please
kai we need a key oh my god you're right 13 seconds to be
restored oh my god there is a limit keep praying keep
praying oh what the fuck are you bad sorry i got new with
bats there were bats there's so many things going on we
gotta leave we gotta leave this place this place is bad this
place is bad bro why the fuck does she get this this map is
Will and Jacob?
Duma!
Why the fuck?
Why could you do this, Duda?
That's....
Hey, wait wait, wait, wait, hold on!
Wait, wait!
Hold on.
Did I raise you?
Are you up?
Okay?
Okay, now I'm getting dumplings!
Yeah, hold on.
Get away.
Get away!
Oh, you're nasty.
Get away.
Oh, shit!
What would big arms you have, Bri?
You have to keep me up.
What big arms you have?
No!
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
My boss, I didn't know what the fuck I was doing.
What the fuck?
I'm sorry, Tuna.
I read the tutorial!
You're so good at this game!
I got the tutorial!
She's actually correct!
I read the tutorial!
Do you know why the fuck were you talking to?
Oh, if you wait, it'll like give you, it'll be like, You
stay in the lobby.
All right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You'll be the demon.
I'll be the demon.
I mean, I have one target and all.
It's free, right?
Free, what are you going to pick free?
I'm curious.
I'll go back to my medic.
It's okay.
I know what to do now.
Wait.
Wait, Kai, weren't you the priest last time?
Yeah, I was.
Yes, you know what you don't want to be you don't want to be
a priest.
You need the priest Get out.
You need a priest.
Thank you.
Are you ready?
All right.
You bye.
Goodbye GG's good luck All right, I'm in 50s.
Oh, I have to possess an imp oh, I might have farmed that
way.
Is this the same?
Is this the mansion in again?
Why the fuck do they get the mansion?
Wait, no, this is a farmhouse Wait, is this a different no,
this is Different?
Same?
I can't tell.
Oh.
I'm gonna be you.
I'm gonna be a nice old lady.
That's fucking right.
Now what do I do?
If I keep walking, they won't know.
They won't know.
They're gonna start off inside.
Oh my god.
No, this is different.
I've never seen this place before.
Okay, I didn't read a tutorial, so...
Good luck to me!
How do I get to the entrance?
Oh my god, I'm lost!
Wait, where am I?
Bob, begin life with demonic.
turns the bell oh
i hear them
yeah i saw her running what the fuck sorry get your ass over
here sorry bro
he just walks off like why do they stay here if they know
it's possessed i know right they have nowhere else they have
nowhere else to live That was frightening.
Is that her?
She went upstairs.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Is that not her?
I don't know.
She went upstairs.
I heard.
Okay.
Oh,
bro.
Oh, bro.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
How did you get there?
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
Why can't we be friends?
You know?
It'll be alright.
What the fuck are you doing?
Oh, fuck.
Lightbox!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I did it, I did it, I did it.
Why can't we be friends?
Oh shit, no!
My door!
Don't worry, I can crawl!
You can't fucking hit me!
That's like you're right!
You can't fucking get me!
I'm crawling away!
What the hell?
What the fuck?
What did you do?
Get off my fucking bag!
What did you say about me not being a good monster?
Dude, that's fucking right.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, that's a hero, right?
Hold on, let me give me like three seconds.
Give me three seconds.
Shit!
Give me three seconds so I can do this.
It's okay, we're fine.
Do you think if I say don't keep her?
The mirror is three times you'll appear behind me.
Oh, what the fuck?
Bro, what the fuck?
Get away from me!
What the fuck was that?
Where are the altars?
How the fuck am I gonna be healed?
Oh my god, guys, I'm pretty fucked up right now.
Get away!
Oh, I missed.
Guys, I missed.
Don't worry.
Get away!
Oh my god, cringe.
Don't worry.
This is my alien.
There you go.
That's fucking right.
Get away from me.
Get away from me!
I need a cooldown!
Okay Okay That's right you don't know what to do That's
fucking right That's I have the high ground now wait Kai
you're almost dead I think Kai's dying I think Kai's almost
dead I Hey
No, that's fine.
I got him.
That's fucking right.
Oh, that's fucking life.
Oh, come here.
Goodbye
Where did I go?
That's wrong person
That's fucking right.
No, that's fucking right.
What do you do about that?
Nothing!
No, I'm not.
No, I'm not!
You don't know where I am!
Get back here!
Get me alone!
Oh, wait.
Guys, I don't know how to get down.
Get away!
Get away from me!
Leave me alone!
I'm just an old lady!
That's so fucked up!
That's so fucked up.
Oh no, we gotta find...
We gotta light the altar.
Okay, I hear you.
Yeah.
you this is so fucked up guys oh my god bro fuck you fuck
you guys that's fucking right that's right you guys deserve
that oh that's fucking right that's fucking right That's
fucking right!
That's fucking right!
Fuck it!
Yo!
That dude just sit!
There you go.
Okay.
We need a health item.
Goodbye.
Where the fuck is the hues?
How many times I teach you a lesson?
That's so fucked up that you guys won't it's so fucked up
you guys will bully the elderly.
It's so fucked up That's so fucked up guys Oh my god, oh
people built this city
That's so fucked up
Wow That's fucked up That's fucked up, guys.
There you go.
I'm learning.
That's fucking right.
Yes!
No!
Get blown away!
No, you don't.
That's fucked up!
You're like capping the heels.
I can't heal because you're literally capping.
You're literally getting healed.
That's fucked up.
You don't hear that?
That's so fucked up.
How am I supposed to heal?
I'm not supposed to heal!
Bro, get off the fucking heels.
That's fucking...
I think she's here.
That's fucking right I am!
That's exactly what the door is!
No!
Yes!
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna camp you.
No!
Don't do this!
This is so gross.
Nobody will save your life now!
No!
That's a king right!
That's a king right.
No!
One can save you now.
it's fucking right you die now oh you want to crawl back
that's right you want to try crawling back
no one he's gonna save you no every time you pick me up it
resets my counter and so we're just gonna beat you for a
Okay, don't worry, I can wait.
Oh, dink, thanks.
We can wait here.
Don't worry.
Wee!
Duna!
Hey!
Help!
And there she goes.
She's gone.
She's gone forever.
Bree's never coming back, guys.
She's never coming back.
Holy shit, your feet are looking rough.
Dude, your toes.
I'm gonna observe.
So, yum, yum, yum, she's not coming back for you.
Yum, yum, yum.
You can get your nails done.
I think red would look really good on your toenails.
I figured out the game.
Where are you?
Oh, I should heal.
Actually.
What the fuck?
There's nothing here.
Oh, it's right here.
Juna, say something, Juna.
You're the last one.
Juna.
Oh my god, there's so many.
Open a portal?
Wait, what's this?
Turn invisible?
Let's do it.
Oh, Juna.
Juna.
You're gonna do the silence?
The silent run?
Oh.
No, she's downstairs.
I hear you, Juna.
I hear you.
You're somewhere around.
Oh, Juna.
Come on, Juna, say something.
Juna, keep talking.
I'm trying to find you.
Oh, full heal.
I'm going full heal.
She has to be here somewhere.
We're going to go.
Where the fuck did she go?
What the fuck?
Where is she?
Oh my god, she's just trying to one man clutch this.
I'll keep peeling until I'm full HP.
Until I find her.
Check every closet?
Oh, you're right.
Let's check every closet.
No closet for you.
What
the fuck?
Where am I?
Hello?
Get
over here!
Get over here!
Respect your elders!
I'm outside now.
I'm coming for you.
Oh shit, that's... I can't leave the fuck.
Fucking, fucking...
Bannister blocked me.
Juna?
Where did you go?
Juna.
Juna, you fucking...
You gotta die eventually!
Your friends are all dead!
All your friends are dead!
Get over here!
I hear you.
All your friends are literally...
Are you in here?
that's my game right i'm coming for you no you can't that's
a game right get batted
outside for like 10 minutes you tubing by yourself in the
corner with your little camera i'm sitting inside
You let your friends die.
You let Kai die.
Kai left me to die.
Kai left me to die so it was only fair.
Please understand.
I did it for the end game.
You did it for your own selfish games.
Spokers are different.
But you still die.
And then two of those went out the building.
Never came back.
Did I just look up and I see you two on the fucking roof?
What is going on?
The fact that you let me kidnap Bree up on the roof and you
guys couldn't do anything about it.
Yeah, I was watching.
You were playing with her body.
I fell off the other side of the roof and you guys weren't
there to- I was on the ground.
Yeah, she was like, you guys!
Help!
This is just taking pictures.
She got the camera out.
You can't have saved her.
Like, she literally fell off the roof and you just let her
die.
No, but I thought she was dead already.
Yeah!
No!
I love it every time it sets it so you get 30 seconds every
time I was playing with my food and you still didn't save
her that's so fucked up I'm honestly like so surprised we
lasted so long that first game now like the first 20 minutes
is like how do I attack because I could just only crawl and
then it pulled me the button.
We just crawling around.
That's like, what's Juno?
I was so confused.
It's okay.
It's good.
No, Juno, you purposely let us go through all the objectives
to see what it was like, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course, of course.
Trust.
Oh, so generous.
Yeah, that's so generous.
I can't believe that.
You guys bullied the elderly, though.
That's so fucked up.
For my Spanish.
That elderly killed me.
That elderly dressed into the roof and then made fun of me.
Only did that because you three ganged up on the sweet old
lady Yeah You guys surrounded me It was self-defense It was
self-defense It's kind of the only one that has him play the
demon right Yeah Holy shit Well It's time for you to I don't
know why I'm scared I'm the demon
This will be fun this will be fun This will be fun I'm just
ready.
Now I'm going to mute now.
I'm muting.
Goodbye.
Goodbye forever.
Okay.
Anyway.
Kill machine.
Okay.
I'm grabbing everything.
There's like med kits.
Why did you not grab the med kit?
There's literally first aid.
Okay.
okay i'm grabbing med kit yeah there's a dog clicker okay
wait no can you wait can you pick up the medic med kits i
don't think so these are only reserved for me you can no no
no you yeah yeah i picked it up yeah yeah maybe it was like
xp i have the xp when i was when i was when i I think we got
more XP now.
Because I played Survivor, I can probably pick it up now too
if I played the Mim-Mim.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
I have the med kit.
I can actually heal.
I can heal now.
You can actually do your med kit.
You finally got the proper license.
I have the license to heal.
Let me see.
What does, what does, what do my things do?
This has to be the demon, right?
Who's this guy?
Oh, look at your dog!
Look at your dog!
Look at my dog!
Where is he?
Where is she?
There's a dog here.
Oh, that's so cute.
He's patrolling.
He's doing his job.
Yeah, he's doing his job.
All right, we gotta find me.
Wait, we got...
Why are you...
Oh, that was...
Oh, no, that's an enchantment.
That means she was near because she was enchanted.
Okay, so we gotta...
We gotta find candles.
Oh, really?
I heard her.
Wait, I hear.
I hear her.
We hear you, Kai.
Kai, speak.
Oh, right here.
Right here.
That's fucking right.
Get away.
Leave.
Holy shit.
That's fucking right.
Stun locker, stun locker.
Skedaddle it.
Yeah!
Oh, I kicked her out.
That's like it, right?
Believe her!
No, she got, she, like, teleported away, like, when you get
hit her too much.
Wait, we gotta find the candle.
Oh, my God.
Wait, the dog sits on this, like, this portal on the ground.
Oh!
There's just, like, this giant red portal that's blowing.
It's upstairs.
Wait, where's, where's Judah?
Judah, where are you doing?
What are you doing out here?
Get back inside.
We gotta do our mission.
finally paid off i can climb walls oh my god get inside
before she drags you to the roof get inside and she can
climb down bro what the fuck why did you i thought that was
i just wanted to see if i could the possibility was there
all right all right let's oh my gosh oh my gosh she's just a
hospital you gotta find Wait, she was behind us!
Don't worry, I have the med kit!
Yeah.
I dropped it, take it.
Thank you!
Yeah, we can heal now.
We can heal.
Oh shit.
Don't worry, I have night vision.
I took my night vision pill.
Oh, I have a- I have a- Alright, I'm looking for- Looking
for the- Here, here, here, here, here, right here.
Oh shit, okay!
Get away!
I have a gun!
I missed.
Uh...
Get away!
That's what I want.
Come over here!
Let me show you!
We need- we didn't- Oh!
Oh, she's invincible!
She's invincible!
Oh, that's not good!
That's not good!
Leave, leave, leave, leave, leave, leave, leave, leave,
leave, leave, leave, leave, leave!
Oh, she's invincible!
Yes, she is!
No!
Oh my god!
We're sorry, no!
We're sorry!
It wasn't joke!
We love the elderly!
We love the elderly so much!
No!
Please!
Do you really love the elderly?
Yes, it was true.
I would never lie about that.
You know that.
I always...
No, please.
That was a joke.
It was a joke.
Because I loved it, but I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Watch where you make your little jokes now, huh?
scared guys please please i'm so scared
oh she's okay she oh she's fine it's fine it's fine okay
guys we're okay we're okay now we're fine we need to find a
candle we haven't said anything yet we haven't i'm healing
myself i I realized the first aid kit only gives you a plus
7.5.
Oh.
This is not good.
Oh my god.
Guys.
Oh, get her away.
Oh, Jesus.
Put the leaf blower away.
Get her away.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my god.
Guys, I'm not okay.
I'm not.
I apologize.
I mean, you're so sore.
I killed you Sorry Oh What the fuck?
It's okay Guys we have to do something We done nothing guys
We done We haven't found a single cat though You lied?
I got two matches We haven't found anything Do you know
where the stuff are?
Do you know where the Wait where's Bri?
Where's Bri?
Oh shit Yeah Are you gonna?
Okay yeah yeah yeah Take a picture Yeah, look at that.
It's so cute Wait, let's take a group photo Can we take a
group photo?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah I'll crouch down
Okay, you are really tall I'll be for the cooldown Alright,
here you go Wait, wait, what does this do?
There we go, cheese Cheese Oh, that's so fucked up!
Wait, why do I keep getting these like cutscenes?
That's so fucked up.
That is so fucked up.
I'm where are we dead right now?
Get her away!
I'm where are you gonna hit the witty right now?
Oh my god.
Guys.
You can't kill us and we keep pressing each other.
Can I grab?
Oh, I thought I could just grab you.
We're fine.
Yeah, yeah, that's why.
Oh!
Okay, he she threw.
a thing at us.
Leave us alone!
We have the job!
We're just so cute.
We're just having a nice little time.
This is so cute.
Leave us alone.
We have to we have to fucking make money for our families.
You don't care.
You're dead.
You don't have family.
Wait, why do I keep getting wait?
Wait, how do I keep getting just this bitch?
You couldn't get that way.
She couldn't Stop!
Look at her!
She's looking stuck!
What a loser!
Look at her!
Wait, she's almost dead!
We could actually kill her!
We could actually kill her, guys!
Get back here!
We can kill you!
We know you have a weakness now!
No, she's almost dead!
We can kill!
Get her!
Get her down!
We can do this!
We're so bad.
Wait, she's over here.
This is so wittable.
I'm gonna fucking throw up.
Get out.
Get out of here.
I can't wait.
I gotta do this.
I'm gonna fucking throw up.
This is right.
Boom.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
That's not fair.
Guys, don't worry.
Oh, why would you hurt me?
Oh, God.
Where is she doing?
I don't know.
I'm waiting when we hitting Du Bois right now.
Okay.
We'll keep healing Ow Oh shit Oh shit Guys I'm saving you,
I'm saving you, don't worry Don't worry, we can kill her
Okay, let's go back to murder Yeah, yeah, yeah, she can't
get away forever Get over here Where did she, oh she went to
the roof Get back inside, get back inside, she went to the
roof She, get back inside Get back inside, Bree, she's in
the roof She's gonna put you in the roof
She fucking figuring out our weakness, the outside.
The moment we're inside, we're safe.
We're only safe when we're inside.
We still haven't done anything.
Okay, we need our five candles.
Yeah.
Where the fuck would the candles be?
Oh, she's here!
She's on me!
Oh!
I slowed it down.
Oh, shit!
I need you guys to pick me up here.
Rescue me!
Okay.
Medic, medic, medic, medic, medic, medic!
Oh wait, what the fuck?
Medic, medic, medic, medic, medic!
We gotta heal each other!
The moment we can...
Oh fuck.
My...
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
We're fine.
Oh, she dropped!
That's a dog!
Oh shit!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, we're fucked.
Oh, no, oh no.
No, we're not.
He doesn't see me.
Can you look at my dog?
What the fuck, bro?
Can you...
Can you get down?
Oh, wait, shit!
You're coming with me.
Get up!
Stop!
No!
You're coming with me!
Okay.
You couldn't even get her out.
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna let her go.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Where did she go?
Oh, there she is.
She's stuck.
Okay.
Here, kill her, kill her!
She can't, she can't!
She can't fucking leave!
She's like, what if she's literally won?
Get her ass!
She's won!
Oh, fuck.
She's so dead!
We did it!
That's fucking right.
You don't like my dark side?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Well, we know who's the worst demon out there.
I know.
We know who's the worst one out there.
I'm trying to figure out what the thing is.
See what's hard coming.
It is.
It is hard.
All right.
I won't shit on you again.
I'm sorry.
can get a redemption arc as a demon for our last game or
something lg lg would tune us a demon okay okay you got this
okay wait wait wait before before you guys mute me yeah
where should we go yeah like do you want a manor hotel house
or the asylum again which one had we not we should do the
asylum because like we haven't actually do the dokey dokey
the dokey the the last one was the asylum i know i don't
know whichever one honestly whichever one really which one
was the easiest for June.
I think the one that I was in was fairly easy.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, the hotel.
If it wasn't, and it becomes hard, that just makes my ego
better, though, because that means that I did well on it.
Okay, I'll do my best, because I believe in you.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm going to kill you.
I'm kidding.
I'm the priest now.
All right, I'm the engineer again.
Maybe I can actually figure out how to play this time.
All right, muting.
Yep.
All right.
Oh, I still can't do it above.
I want to get the dove.
I can do.
Some syringe gun I can do.
I can.
Oh, someone doesn't have enough XP.
Oh, wait.
I'm stupid.
Oh.
Okay, I have armor.
Someone's in armor.
to defense all those inside it dash yeah okay okay we're
good we're good we're good okay i'm ready spiritual burst
shockwave orbs and i got spiritual burst i got telekinesis
can i can i invest in this i got everything all right hello
did you get the dog clicker hello were you able to get the
dog did you get the dog dog clicker i don't know it's in the
middle here yeah it's right here uh uh you get it oh yeah i
did oh my god we have the dog okay guys i think i can do
this we're gonna win we're so okay we didn't do this there's
no way as long as we stick together we're fine oh yeah i got
the car okay we gotta find candles okay we gotta find
candles where the fuck are the candles okay easy okay oh i
found one i found one it's just i found two i found two wait
wait wait what's it look like it's just it's a candle
Yeah, yeah, I see, I see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we have...
We need two more.
All right.
Okay.
Use this for now.
All right, we see that.
I don't think we need armor, right?
What does that magnetic detector do?
It senses a demon.
Wait.
Yeah.
Oh, that's her, that's her, that's her!
That's her!
That's why she jumped!
NPCs can't jump!
I figured it out!
NPCs don't jump!
That's automatically her!
Oh, my God!
You funny!
Oh, no, she's actually, she can navigate.
Oh, no, she is.
She knows how to crawl.
No, she knows how to crawl.
What a freak.
Oh, literally a fucking freak.
A fucking freak.
This is why you got bullied and became a demon.
Okay, we need to...
Why you got bullied?
We need to find the...
We need to find one more candle.
Ooh, dokey.
I can actually do my task.
Oh my god.
It's huge.
She's finally learned.
We need to find another candle.
We're literally missing one candle.
Oh, no.
That's bandage.
Where the fuck?
How much is, though?
We're literally missing one candle.
Oh no, guys.
I split up with a gang.
This is not good.
important for the candle, though.
Would there be candles upstairs?
Right?
Collect blood from crying statues?
Maybe there'd be candles upstairs.
Wait, do we do it?
Am I stuck?
Guys!
Oh.
What?
Oh, I was in the table.
I was like, what the fuck?
Guys, are you found the last candle yet?
Why
is he her?
What the...
Is that...
Was that you?
Did you guys... We did it!
We did it!
It's me.
Yeah, it's me.
I found, like, an enchanted...
One of the fucking...
Or minions.
We need to find... Collect blood from Christ.
Is that the statues outside?
Oh, I'm lost.
Guys, what do crying statues look like?
Guys?
Oh, it must be outside, right?
Guys, I found her.
I found the statues.
I'm out.
That's outside.
Oh, okay.
It's outside.
Get away!
Get away from us!
You're not wanted, Juna!
Get away!
Don't buggy!
You can't tell me what to do!
Nobody thinks you're cool!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can try, but you can't- We did it!
Place the candles.
Oh, where's the circle?
No, no, I'm good.
I'm good.
I think we did it!
Place the candles in a circle and like them.
Where the fuck is that?
And where?
Yeah, where?
Oh, good reason not to fucking shoot you right now, Juna.
Don't wait, watch this.
That's fucking right, you did...
No!
She's a demon!
Demons don't deserve love!
She's so sweet!
She's so sad!
She's just manipulating you!
She's just acting!
It's just acting!
Don't be don't be a little bitch All right, we got all right
guys.
We got find the circle.
Do you think it's in the basement?
I thought it'd be outside or we could be or maybe it's in
that weird altar place It says like place the blood violet.
We got to find what the fuck are you doing?
What why are you looking at this poor man?
Bro, what did you do to this poor?
guy bro what the fuck what's wrong with you what is wrong
with you all right maybe downstairs it could be downstairs
yeah yeah it has to be downstairs but it where's Bree I'm
gonna try and keep well downstairs Bree Bree will be fine
right she'll be fine yeah she's she's full HP there's no way
good Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
It was oh, what the fuck you okay.
Oh, you you knew it All right, all right, she knew it too
apparently Junus come in She's so confused Oh, not the
lights.
We gotta figure out the lights.
Oh Oh, there's a circuit breaker right here Oh, nice.
Dude, this is like the thing I'm best at.
I just keep fixing.
When you have five sets of electric...
Yeah, you literally got a degree for this.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Let me show you my license.
Here you go.
Nice.
I am finally a proper medic.
It took her 20 years to get her medical degree.
We have fine electric cables.
Where would that be?
I've never seen what it looked like, either.
Maybe out six.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, we found the generator.
Yeah, yeah, but...
Yeah, I'm gonna go upstairs and see...
Oh, here's another one.
Oh, that's a window.
Oh, we found two generators.
What would the electric cable look like?
Yep.
But what would the cables look like?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I've got the generators.
I've got more matches.
I'm right here behind you.
Juna!
Juna, where are you, Juna?
Juna, you're not beating the allegations about you and your
skills and more.
Monsters.
I don't like this.
Oh, that's you.
That was on reflex.
Where the fuck?
Where is the electric cable?
I don't know what they look like.
I don't know either.
Oh, this has to be something.
Oh, we put a generator here.
That's our goal.
Yeah.
We have to go here.
Maybe downstairs.
Maybe go back in basement.
Maybe.
Where the fuck did Juna go?
Juna, Juna, get back in, Juna!
Juna, back!
I like how everybody always possessed the elderly.
Juna, we know...
No, she's back.
Oh, no, she's right.
She's literally right here.
Juna, get back in, Juna!
Juna!
I'm just a baby.
It's perfect.
Holy shit.
Oh,
I found it!
It's just on the floor.
It's just like wires on the floor.
Oh, oh, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Just look on the floor.
No!
Why the fuck did you do this to this poor man?
Damn, Juna.
Juna, this is not looking good for you.
that'll be five dollars all right five dollars is that him
what is that that's not juna that can't be juna no it's just
a man oh yeah it's just a man just a man oh shit the demon
has turned it off oh my god where the oh there's another
generator find the incantation table Oh, hey Hey, what are
you doing?
Yeah, you know
You're right I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry You're
right, you're right You're having family
Please!
Please, don't!
I also have a family!
Please!
What happened to family?
I don't understand!
I've been nothing but kind!
What?
Oh!
oh nice okay okay we're okay we're okay now we're okay oh my
god how i get back inside oh no i get back inside we're okay
now i'm restoring the power i hope that's like oh nice bro
this electrical this electric key
difficult are you guys okay
bro where the fuck is the electrical cable I found it guys I
found it go to the table guys I found it go to the table
Junet, just stop being a little girl.
Okay, I'm here, Mary.
I found it, found it.
We go to the table.
We go, we go outside.
Oh my god, bro.
Oh my god, it actually worked for the first time ever.
The stupid anti-invisibility thing worked.
Get the fuck out of here.
Get out of here.
Get out of him!
Nobody!
Oh, it's because I had armor, bitch.
It's because I had armor, bitch.
Oh, guys, guys.
We gotta, like, not let her just do that to us.
Let's just go to the table.
Guys, let's just go.
Guys.
Guys, where the fuck I left?
I left.
I know what the objective is.
Where the fuck?
Whoa!
Oh.
Hey.
Okay, so she's right behind me.
She's right behind me.
All right.
Finding the table.
Woo.
Where the fuck is the table?
I found it.
nice objective time oh no okay okay there we go and then am
I is this correct no no that was not correct okay it's
alright they're distracting they're distracting Juno for me
while I figured this out there you go and then we're just
gonna keep turning until this hits yeah i did it oh no am i
bugged forever collect electric oh no i bugged myself oh no
oh did i bugged myself no i did it oh no i can't run no i
can't run no guys Oh no.
Guys, wait!
How did they all die?
What did you do, Juna?
What did you do?
Juna!
What happened?
What do you mean?
How the fuck did they all die?
I was doing a puzzle!
Okay, tell me how you You got this.
Get away.
Don't do it.
Don't.
I don't want it.
You want to talk about it.
You want to talk about it?
No.
No, I don't.
I don't want to talk about it.
I can't give up.
How the fuck?
What did you guys do?
I was doing a puzzle.
Juna, you're too good at this.
What happened?
We were doing a puzzle.
just saw you and then we both went down and I turned back to
ask for help and you just disappeared.
I thought you were okay.
I was trying to turn to.
I was like, oh, that'll be fine.
I'm going to do this puzzle and then no, we were.
You were not fine.
Did I do good?
I was a little bad in the beginning, but yeah, you're a
natural.
It makes sense.
Redemption arc.
Juna redemption arc right there.
minutes to 14.
That was so good.
The evil laughing throughout really sweet.
You know, right?
I just hear her fucking devilish laughing.
That was like, that was great.
I turned around, I was like, we do this.
I know.
Holy shit.
But you didn't mean to, like, purposely leave them, though,
right?
No, I was like, oh, it'll be fine.
I'm gonna do the fucking punch.
Yeah, your purposefully left us.
So your purposefully left us.
They'll be fine.
I'm gonna do the puzzle.
They're gonna protect me from the puzzle.
No.
And I was like, I'm sorry.
I learned.
I learned things on my shoes.
I'm sorry, you relied on the wrong people.
I'm sorry.
I realized that was a mistake.
I was the medic and I was always the first one going into a
shooter.
had one gun and it was a little serene but i wasn't ready
man i was like oh maybe maybe i shouldn't have left oh yeah
you think i'm so glad that crossed your mind yeah that was
the deal definitely definitely shouldn't have left it's okay
it's okay that was fun yeah that was awesome that was This
is why we had to go in blind without the tutorial.
It's better!
It's better because the demon is so overpowered when you
figure out how to actually play the demon.
I loved when I played and the first thing I heard was, oh my
god, she knows how to play the game.
Oh my god!
I was like, oh no, we're not gonna have a good time.
she knows how to play it's okay but i i guess i actually
have nothing else to say the demons we made along the way we
killed along the way we killed along the way there we go
appreciation for elderly women oh my god children are the
elderly who would have thought i feel like i just did
something unethical i gotta go to the nursing home bring
them cupcakes for some community service now i don't know i
feel like normally obligated right now they deserve it
things they're touching you'll never know the next elderly
could be the next demon you'll never know remember to your
elders right or else they might kill you yeah exactly this
is why we put them in homes because we're worried about them
turning into demons they turn into demons they'll just turn
into demons between each other retirement homes are actually
like homes for churches yeah oh my god That was so fun.
You're a boy, a boy, a boy.
A boy, a boy.
We all be safe.
Yeah, wait, do any of you guys have announcements for like
the coming week?
It's just a collab.
It's a collab.
I mean like, I'm supposed to, it's like I normally just ask
and then you're like, wow, that's so cool.
You're so slow.
I mean being nice to Kier.
He's like, nice?
He's just like, nice?
Why?
humor has to be a genius right nobody's nice for no reason
what do you mean i always ask this question it's true she
does it's true i'm like hi are you do have anything upcoming
and she goes yeah i'm gonna do this and i'm like oh wow
that's so nice it's exactly what the words are that she says
every time that's exactly how i sound like oh my god
weird roleplay session I think I walked into some roleplay
shit here at the moment It's like a VR chat where you join a
random world and then there's two these two people
It's okay, Juno, she doesn't understand us Yeah, I should
understand our bond, our relationship
Nooo like it, you know, like doing it in public, like this
PDA.
Yeah, this is a part of it.
This is part of it.
But you're part of it to do it in public?
And so, like, people would watch this.
That's when our everything's out.
We're still covered, bro.
So now, we're still covered.
We have, like, we have space for Jesus, too.
Also the baby.
Jesus, are you the baby?
Is this an exhibition?
Yes, this is a- Is this- Is this a- Is this a- Is this an
exhibition?
Because there's no private parts, no key.
Oh my god.
We're still alone.
Now we know who's definitely going to hell.
She learned something from the demons.
Oh god.
We know- We- You know, gates are closed for someone here.
That was fun, though.
Thank you.
Thank you, Juno, for inviting Kai and Bree.
Thank you for inviting me.
Thank you, Juno, for playing this game with me.
I was going to try this game out.
So thank you, guys.
I hope that was fun.
We had a lot of fun murdering people.
Yeah, I had a great time.
Here, Gigi, guys, Gigi's.
I'm going to go talk to my chat now.
Bye, bye.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Oh, yeah, that was so fun.
I think that was really, really fun, guys.
It was great meeting them for the first time.
I've never talked to them before.
It was like the first...
Oh, I talked to Juna before.
She actually went to one of my meet and greets a long time
ago.
I think I told this story before.
Obviously, there's no bonds of it anymore.
But Juna was actually...
one of I think like one of the um I think like the only
vtuber that like came to my meet and greet and like
purposely requested to like meet me during one of my meeting
greets and he like brought her like fucking screen over to
like talk to me and everything and um and I know like I'm
like her oh she's so I was like oh yeah yeah I'm gonna I'll
like I'll ask her if she wants to it was she wants to do a
collab with me because like I I remember like that that like
I was like one of her oh she's and I said like you can
invite anybody to join us because I really wanna play this
game anyway so i was like you know what i'll ask her if she
wants to play and um had a great time had a great time
playing with uh juna kai and brey and they're really fun you
know what i i kept fucking okay you know what brey's voice
reminds me of brie's voice remind remember when i like was
showing you guys that song about um from like garfunkel like
what's her name she her her voice fucking remind like
literally was like almost Exactly like that And Oh my god,
what was her voice is literally almost me you and Steve.
Yeah, I was like I was like, oh my god, like her voice is
literally Just like her voice.
It's like Kate McCoochie.
That's her name, right?
Yeah, she sounds just like Kate McCoochie Not no joke like
literally one-to-one because like Kate McCoochie was the
voice of What was her name?
DuckTales.
The girl in DuckTales?
The little girl?
Fuck.
What was her name?
Ah, what was that little girl's name in DuckTales?
Uh.
You know what I'm talking about?
What was that name?
Uh, that little girl in DuckTales.
Oh my gosh, girl.
I'm just gonna go.
Webby.
She sounds just like Webby.
Doesn't she?
I was like, oh my god, that's literally Webby's voice.
Because like, K.
Mikuchi, like, has, like, the same, the same, like, she
does, like, a lot of voice acting for TV shows.
And, like, she literally sounds like her.
Who does?
Bree.
Bree literally sounds like Webby from DuckTales.
remember i was like oh my gosh this is like one to one
exactly her voice i was like holy shit that's literally her
like how like people are like oh my god dokie you sound like
that fucking girl in gravity falls even though i don't think
so i don't think i sound like i think like i would sometimes
hit the intonations of her but like i don't think i i
personally don't think i actually sound like her like what's
her name i keep forgetting but like the girl who that main
character Sometimes, apparently sometimes, I can sound like
Mabel when I talk, but I don't, I don't hear it.
But I think if I go higher, I think if I go a higher pitch,
I sound like Mabel.
Um, yeah.
So, but I swear, Brie sounds exactly like Webby from Death
Tales.
And she sounds like, like, because like, uh, the actress
does, like, so many voice acting for, like, different, uh,
uh, Vellma!
It's like a mix between Vellma.
and webby it sounds just like it sounds like almost like
velma and webby if you think about it like if you just
listen to it and i was like oh my god every time she opens
her mouth i was like oh my god i feel like i feel like
that's just velma and webby it's so cool it's so cool i was
like it's such a unique voice um it's like a really unique
voice too so i was like that's really cool um anyway i had a
great time my great time meeting them it was really really
fun um playing with the girls and yeah i'm like really tired
so i'm gonna rest a little bit we do have one more stream we
do have one more stream today uh which is like good night
dragons uh so So, I'm going to rest now and then we're going
to hang out later tonight because my brain is like fried at
the moment because I can't talk anymore.
My brain is fried at the moment.
So, like, I can't verbalize anything anymore.
So, I'll see you guys at the next stream, everybody.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!